so i want to start with this we have
here an article from the washington post
written by caroline kitchener
that really lays the pro-abortion
position to bear i think there's no
dancing around the subject here not
really anyway
abortion kills babies and that's a good
thing according to pro boards because
babies are bad and that's that's the
position
laid out in this washington post piece
through the profile of a young mother of
twins and the headline is
this texas teen wanted an abortion
she now has twins
and accompanying the headline is a
picture of um as you can see two
adorable
little twin babies and
we're supposed to to see this picture
and immediately think how sad it is
that
those babies exist
and are alive rather than dead and
dismembered and rotting away somewhere
this is an actual headline the
washington post with pictures of of
little twin babies that says well now
look what you did pro-lifers now these
babies exist
um that's what caroline kitchener of the
washington post wants us to think anyway
when we see infant babies so let's get
to the article
it doesn't get any better in the article
itself um so read you through a little
bit she says um she writes brooke
alexander turned off her breast pump at
604 pm and brought two fresh bottles of
milk over to the bed where her
three-month-old twins lay flat on their
backs red face and crying
running on four hours of sleep the 18
year old tried to feed both babies at
once holding kendall in her arms while
she tried to get olivia to feed herself
her bottle propped up by a pillow but
the bottle kept slipping and the babies
kept wailing and brook's boyfriend billy
high wouldn't be home for another five
hours
please fussy girl brooke whispered she
peeked outside the room just big enough
for a full-size mattress and realized
she had she'd barely seen the sun all
day the windows were covered by blankets
pinned up with thumbtacks to keep the
room cool brook raleigh ventured into
the rest of the house billy's dad had
taken them in when
her mom kicked them out and she didn't
want to get in his way brook found out
she was pregnant late on the night of
august 29th two days before the texas
heartbeat act uh heartbeat act banned
abortions once an ultrasound could
detect cardiac activity around six weeks
of pregnancy it was the most restrictive
abortion law to take affect the united
states in nearly 50 years now
if you're pro-life
meaning that you you love and appreciate
life and you think life is a good thing
right
then you
you hear the first part of this this
profile
and you might think that this will turn
into a story
of like a young mother who was prevented
from from killing her two children
and though she now has financial
hardship she also is experiencing the
beauty of motherhood
and and of her children and she's
grateful to have them and she's learning
to embrace this new and unexpected
reality of motherhood
and like that's that's all a good a good
thing
you know
that's the way you you might see this as
a pro-lifer
but this story is coming to us from a
death worshiping nihilist so it kind of
takes another direction and it continues
texas offers a glimpse of what much of
the country would face if the supreme
court overturns roe v wade this summer
as has been widely expected if the
landmark precedent falls roughly half
the states in the country are expected
to dramatically restrict abortion or ban
it all together creating vast abortion
deserts that will push many into
parenthood
sometimes brooke imagined her life if
she hadn't gotten pregnant and if texas
hadn't banned abortion just days after
she decided that she wanted one she
would have been in school rushing from
class to her shift to texas roadhouse
eyes on a real estate license that would
finally get her out of corpus christi
she pictured an apartment in austin
enough money to trip for a trip to
hawaii where she would swim with
dolphins and water so clear she could
see her toes
now from there
we're told the whole story um of how she
got pregnant then tried to get in for an
abortion before the law took effect but
she couldn't
so then she went for an ultrasound she
was hoping the baby wouldn't have a
heartbeat but then it turned out that
the baby did and in fact there were two
of them so now she has two daughters
and then we get passages like this
if it wasn't for the texas law brook
knew she might not be standing here
she'd probably be studying for her next
exam while billy mastered some new trick
on the quarter pipe she liked to think
that they'd still be together spending
their money on movie tickets and
whataburger instead of diapers and baby
wipes
now
of course the life of a mother of two
beautiful children
is far more meaningful and interesting
and important
than just like hanging out at a fast
food restaurant
so it almost seems like this is supposed
to be a pro-life story right
especially when we're told actually
later on in the in the article it goes
on
for quite a while we're told that um
that brook married the father of her her
children so she did the right thing she
married
the father and they formed a nuclear
family
and that she loves her babies
and she's she's happy to have them now
and we're also told that she doesn't
want to think about what would have
happened without the texas law because
she knows that they probably wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for that law
okay and all of that is in the article
and yet the writer
makes her feelings known in the headline
and also by the fact that she's an
abortion reporter for the washington
post and she's not shy about her
pro-abortion radicalism she re retweets
uh planned parenthood all the time so
she's a an advocate for abortion
and yet it just kind of goes to show
that
even when writing this profile again the
writer caroline kitchener
made her intentions clear
this is supposed to be a sad story
about a woman whose life was destroyed
by the presence of two beautiful
babies
and yet you read through the entire
article and you you're kind of left
thinking well but is this supposed to be
pro-life
because
it it's it sounds like and you know this
pregnancy was an unexpected turn and she
didn't want the pregnancy at first
but now she has the babies and she's
grateful to have them and she's living a
more meaningful life and yeah there are
more challenges now but she's she has
resolve and she's getting past it
and so that's that's a positive thing
right
and now these two uh beautiful babies
are are living whereas before they
whereas they wouldn't have been living
before
and it shows that really any honest
discussion of the issue ends up sounding
pro-life even if it isn't supposed to be
if you're just honest
and you and you tell a story
and it's even if it's we're supposed to
take a pro-abortion message away from it
we don't
because that's where honesty on the
subject of abortion always points to the
pro-life message
and that's especially the case with this
article here well if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell to get more
content like it if you're craving more
content go watch or listen to my full
show at dailywire.com spotify or
wherever you get your podcast
you